per tutti belli e brutti oggi siamo su
un episodio di happy meal signori siamo
sul 170esimo che non sottovaluterei come
episodio visto che oggi facciamo livelli
speciali volevo provare a fare l'ultimo
della lista dei livelli più che sono
diciamo piaciuti di più però la cosa che
mi fa strano che in questa classifica ci
ho capito solo adesso che non ci sono i
livelli più belli sui livelli che è più
vista deciso di ficcarci dentro perché
effettivamente l'ultimo a due stelle non
è che ne ha tante però il creatore ed è
perciò avuto ficca dentro qua in oro la
motivazione proviamo a vederlo non so
non so perché faccia così schifo che è
votato malissimo però non è partito male
quindi non so perché sono due stelle
icesave io in di ok a indy è il nome del
disco tizio indiana e l'ho chiamato
prova chiamiamolo in di ko ei che è
successo bisogna schietta a posto c'è
una persona e tipo rock swing quali devo
aggrappare a sta cosa ok pur cup
tutto bene quel che finisce senza le
braccia però no no aiuto no non mi
toccare lo vito che mai via
che schifo e dai ragazzi non si posso
lamentare forse perché non è all'altezza
di quelli che sono stati ficcati in
classifica perché lo si trova
addirittura due stelle mi sembra
esagerato dai ecco bene bene tutto a
posto
ahia occhio che voti piglia bravo sono
riuscito ragazza binario sta andando
avanti e occhio vecchio rock
no non ci credo alla svelta felice
ancora possibilità di salvarsi
caponi indice l'avevo fatta era il
finale bastava che tenete né si che
peccato
super meat boy che senso super nonno
jacques poi va bene è facile per
l'occasione questo che possono essere
dei risvolti positivi buono tipo questo
aiuto bravissimo bravo nonno ho vinto ho
vinto no ho vinto vinto e questo finale
non promettono moneta
manca una moneta dove la prendo manca
una mano non c'è un finale non c'è un
finale però è finito del legacy of his
al quds al volete fa che livello
incredibile si of thieves questo è sì o
è sì o sì o the peawees il cav h sono
spaccato una mano fa niente
adesso invece fa devo prendere tutte e
17 le monete sen sicuri non la vedo
proprio
c'è il tu c'hai tui dirmi che indiana ma
il turbo quanto sta sulle rotaie e io
non lo sapevo se schiaccia barra
spaziatrice sad turbo da ragazzi non lo
sapevo se io ho scoperto adesso dopo sei
anni
anzi sette anni di happy with che sito
premi barra spaziatrice con questo
personaggio fa il turbo
c'è da proprio uno sprint in più madonna
ok ok ciao vita giusta stavolta credo
sempre purtroppo ma va bene sono vivo ne
ho ancora tipo un sacco di monete da
prendere quindi sì ma ragazzi vi rendete
conto di quanti ostacoli ci sono
infiniti le sto di vero ce ne sono
veramente troppi
come posso ok c'è ovviamente una
moltitudine di ostacoli e pieno aiuto
non si guida con la faccia e io madonna
cadeau a haga l'ultimo tentativo questo
è perché porca vacca due ore ci ho messo
arrivare qua va dal indietro vado all
indietro fa niente
vado lì dietro arpioni però da ha però
fi però figo però figo jackson su un
altro livello a tema dark souls l'ex
white sembra anche quelle sulle anime va
bene se fa aveva da hiltebrand però però
chi non ha giocato a dark souls e non le
sa queste cose me le spiego io
più o meno come faccio se guardate nido
di sabac aiuto cosa formi significano a
di significa che devono schivarli sono
stupido questo vi fa capire quante volte
sono morto quando giocava dark souls
tantissimi ragazzi tantissime con io
sono morto io sono morto tantissime
volte magazine duncan belli queste
bellissime l'asl end anche ragazze
geniale ho fatto che a nessuno io mi sa
che devo farlo con mio figlio però vabbè
proviamoci no ragazzi vincere
impossibile qua perché se cerca di fare
una roba che teoricamente non è da non è
non dovresti fare questo nel livello
però ho visto un traguardo
distrutti vorrei di sfruttarlo l'abbiamo
sfruttato raffaella la home ner
soprattutto facendo quelli che sono
stati giudicati più brutti ma non mi
sembrano così arrivato spara i robot va
bene buongiorno of cavalcata schiatta è
una versione di quello era un boss devo
farlo fuori
ok scusate mi dicevo è la versione di
blade runner un po strana poi valore
cioè il tipo non è quello di blade
runner mio futuro
però va beh tutto ok tutto ok
tranquilli questo secco orca aiac ma è
difficilissimo qualche ora che l'hanno
fatto più difficile cioè non ho neanche
capito se è fattibile però è per questo
che la gente l'ha votato poco perché era
impossibile da finire però ok bene è
schioppa
devo ricordarmi di non fermarmi là sopra
ragazzi che ci sono i laser che mi fanno
fuori però ce la posso fare adesso che
siamo all'ottavo tentativo ce la farò ci
siamo
lo supero ok via dietro dietro dietro
lettori 32 veloce veloce la società
schivare aiuto dove devo andare
e qua egli ha porca vacca una nobile
gambe lo steccato e stata una battaglia
veramente difficile però sono fiero di
me stesso ma ogni tanto succede waste
land due ci hanno fatto anche l'uno già
abita europa quel poco va bene vediamo
vedersi arrivare c'è estrema sta roba
che sono stati votati poco solo perché
la gente si aspetta una roba incredibile
comunque non sono male per niente ma che
roba
fallo tu livello così ma scusami come
anche lo sullo sfondo della città
radioattiva che fa questo è meglio di
fallout 76 ragazze c'è gente col costume
anti radiazioni che è morta però questa
una lingua cos'è ragazzi cos'è sta roba
aiuto lo superarla ma gino io sono
l'unico che saltando col fumo riesce a
fracassarsi ma come ho fatto a morire
dimmi che sono le radiazioni non sono io
che non so andare sul fuoco perché non
sono io che non sa andare sul podio ci
siamo nel momento del salto barca ma
casta lingua stata di infilare dio mio
o mio dio è stato veramente difficile
già ambito ho capito che devo saltare le
cose sono un po come cosa vuoi che
faccia adesso salta di sopra ok all
istruzione di dove devi andare lo vedo
c'è una strada aprendo quella c'è una
bacall
ma come devo detonare sta roba ma poi
tra tutte quelle tra tutti i personaggi
che potevamo c'è potevi scegliere la
mano il pogo man che proprio difficile
da comandare negli spazi stretti
il bacio va beh meno male che non sono
morto in tutto questo perché testate sul
muro per poi rimanere senza testa e ci
metti un secondo meno male cioè lavabo
natale che chiudeva ma come c'è ma vabbè
ok molto bene il resto livello prima o
poi avrà una fine che un mondo
abbandonato nel nulla devo saltare sulle
cose
ok cioè io non spa allora c'era uno
spazietto c'era uno spazietto un ho
preso quello che hanno nome lo rifaccio
tutto c'erano andate a cagare perché
vedo gli sia piaciuto iscriviti al
canale spiaggia della campanini la prima
e ragionati suoi video che escono
ragazzi e noi come sempre ci vediamo al
prossimo video della ragazza
[Musica]